bonsoir madame bonjour mademoiselle
bonsoir monsieur je vous parle pour la
première fois comme candidat à la
présidence de la république
je me suis déjà dressé à vous en
souvenez pour vous commenter la
situation économique de la france
lorsque j'avais la responsabilité de
l'économie et que je travaillais aux
côtés du président georges pompidou
mais maintenant il s'agit une autre
fonction la présidence de la république
et d'un autre sujet la politique de la
france
j'ai dit que pendant cette campagne je
voulais regarder la france au fond des
yeux la france pour moi qu'est ce que
c'est c'est l'ensemble de toutes celles
et de tous ceux qui habitent qui
grandissent qui travaillent qu'ils
vieillissent sur notre sol et donc pour
moi la france c'est chacune et chacun
d'entre vous et c'est pourquoi je vous
regarde ce soir et c'est pourquoi aussi
vous ne regardez vous allez choisir
votre président c'est à dire l'homme qui
exercera les plus hautes responsabilités
et qui aura le devoir de conduire la
france dans des circonstances prévisible
mais aussi de faire face à l'imprévu et
qui parlera à votre en votre nom
dans le monde moderne pour choisir ce
président vous poser je pense deux
questions qui choisir et le choisir pour
quoi faire
d'abord qui choisir quand on se présente
pour un emploi n'importe quel emploi
quand on se présente pour un travail
n'importe quel travail on vous demande
qui êtes vous
et c'est pourquoi lorsqu'on se présente
à cette fonction qui est la plus
importante des fonctions de la vie
française il faut dire qui on est aussi
au cours de ma prochaine édition qui
aura lieu lundi soir et qui sera la
dernière de la soirée
j'essaierai de vous dire qui je suis et
pourquoi je me présente à la présidence
de la république qui choisir
mais pour quoi faire et c'est ici que se
pose la question du programme concernant
le programme je voudrais rappeler que le
président des républicains en france des
pouvoirs très important les plus
importants mais qu'il ya aussi un
gouvernement qui a ses responsabilités
et qu'il ya aussi un parlement qui a ses
droits
et c'est pourquoi il s'agit moins de
programmes que de perspectives dans
quelle direction le président se
propose-t-il de conduire d'orienter
d'entraîner la france pour moi ces
perspectives sont les suivantes
l'indépendance et la puissance pour la
france la justice et la sécurité pour
les français et pour la politique
française
le changement sans le risque de mort
pour la france l'indépendance et la
puissance
la france n'est pas un des plus grands
pays du monde mais c'est un grand pays
et elle a le droit de décider elle même
où elle veut aller et comment elle veut
d'y aller si la france veut être
indépendante elle doit se donner le
moyen de cette indépendance c'est à dire
la puissance et notamment la puissance
moderne qui vous le savez bien celle de
l'économie la france est un pays
indépendant
mais ce n'est pas un pays solidaire nous
faisons partie d'un ensemble l'europe
dont nous avons le devoir d'organiser
l'union au cours des prochaines années
pour aboutir en 1981
pour les français la justice et la
sécurité au cours des dernières années
beaucoup de choses ont été accomplies et
d'ailleurs il suffit de se souvenir si
peu que ce soit de ce qu'était la france
il ya quinze ans où il ya dix ans pour
le savoir mais il est vrai que notre
société n'est pas encore une société
juste et il est vrai que les français
n'ont pas encore vis-à-vis des risques
de la vie économique la sécurité à
laquelle ils ont droit
c'est pourquoi nous devons faire de la
société française une société plus juste
plus fraternelle plus égale et nous
devons concernant la sécurité sécurité
des travailleurs pour ce qui est de
l'emploi sécurité des personnes âgées au
point de vue des ressources de la
vieillesse sécurité devant les épreuves
de la vie et notamment la maladie
nous devons accroître et garantir la
sécurité des français
je vous parlerais de l'ensemble de ces
questions au cours de mes prochaines
émissions et je consacrerai on est mis
sur la plus importante aux problèmes de
la vie quotidienne des français enfin
pour la politique française
le changement sans le risque le
changement pourquoi parce que le monde
change parce que le temps change parce
que vous changé et que la politique
française doit s'adapter à ce changement
les français le savent mais ils ont une
certaine inquiétude sur les conséquences
du changement
c'est pourquoi je vous propose le
changement sans le risque est maintenant
je voudrais vous demander quelque chose
il faut m'aider je n'ai pas la
prétention et je n'ai même pas le désir
de gagner seul ou de gouverner seul j'ai
le désir de gagner et de gouverner avec
l'appui avec le soutien avec la
confiance des françaises et des français
c'est pourquoi il faut m'aider madame
mademoiselle monsieur je compte sur vous
pour que le jour venu vous puissiez
compter sur moi
[Musique]